from starting out during hollywood's
golden age through to playing one of the
80s most iconic tv characters dame joan
collins's new memoir starts after
dynasty has ended you don't mince your
words in this book i never miss my
letters
i had this tiny tape recorder and i used
to use it when i was working on dynasty
to learn my lines it just gave me total
freedom and i never ever ever thought it
would be published what we hear through
your voice in this we don't hear from
modern celebrities at all because of
council culture would you say that
you're you're anti-woke that you sort of
don't really care what people think i
really don't care that much what people
think of course i do up to a certain
amount but i think that um people are
caring too much about having their
opinions and not being able to say what
they think you can't have debates you
can't throw opinions about what you
think about this particular thing
statues being taken down for example you
can't have that argument with somebody
who wants statues taken down of people
um who they are just
belligerent almost i mean well that's my
experience you talk about boris johnson
in there it's a brilliant description
that you have saying he looks like he
brushes his hair with an egg beater
i mean do you think he's got any better
does carrie need to have a word have you
seen his child his child's hair is even
more wild than than his i like boris i
worked for him he was my editor on the
spectator you talk about um wanting to
use stunt women you talk about the
importance of choreographing fights on
stage as well look what just happened
last
month with the gun
i'd work with guns in films and every
single time that i don't like guns i've
been given a gun i said to the prop man
i said please open it up in front of me
so i can see inside to see that there's
nothing in it can you even imagine what
alec baldwin has been going through
since this has happened i can't even
imagine it must be hell just because
it's cop 26 at the moment uh you played
the ex-wife of an oil uh tycoon on
dynasty of course
would that have worked if he was doing
wind farms what do we
think of the uh
i don't think so life has moved on
could celebrities do with perhaps uh in
all seriousness cutting down the the
private jets and what have you not just
celebrities did you see the amount of
cars that joe biden had i mean i can't i
was watching sky news of course and i i
counted at least 10 cars you see i'm
very opinionated
but we love you for it thank you so much